RIGHT HERE.
GO AHEAD.
IT'S YOU, K.D.
ALL YOU.
>> FOR MY SIXTH PICK OF MY
RESERVES, I'M GOING TO GO WITH A
FIRST-TIMER AGAIN, LaMELO BALL.
>> HIS SPOT OPENED UP ON THE
EASTERN CONFERENCE SIDE BECAUSE
OF INJURY.
>> HE PLAY FIVE MINUTES?
THAT IS MUST SEE FIVE MINUTES.
>> LeBRON, MAKE HIM SWEAT IT
OUT!
TAKE ANYBODY ELSE!
>> WITH THE SIXTH PICK IN THE
SECOND ROUND, PER REQUEST OF THE
CHUCKSTER, I'M GOING TO GO WITH
FRED VanVLEET.
>> THERE YOU GO!
FIRST TIMER.
FIRST TIMER IN HIS SIXTH SEASON.
>> K.J. JUST NEEDS SIZE RIGHT
NOW TO ME.
REMEMBER LAST TIME?
>> LAST YEAR, LeBRON SAID HE
NEEDED SIZE SO HE TOOK A 6'2"
GUY.
>> I NEED SOME SIZE FOR SURE.
I'M GOING TO NEED SOME SIZE AND
DEFENSE AND THE INTERIOR AND
ESPECIALLY WITH GIANNIS AND
LeBRON JAMES PLAYING.
>> WITHOUT QUESTION.
>> SUCH GREAT BASKETBALL THIS
YEAR, I NEED SOMEBODY TO OFFSET
SO I'M GOING WITH RUDY GOBERT.
>> I AGREE.
>> THAT WORKED OUT NICELY FOR
YOU.
>> THAT WORKED OUT NICELY.
>> HE CAN'T LET PEOPLE RUN
THROUGH THE LANES.
GOT SOMEBODY DEFENDING BACK
THERE.
>> WHEN SOMEBODY WANT OUT, LET
THEM GO.
DON'T LET THEM GO.
>> THAT'S WHY I CUT MY HAIR OFF.
>> SO JAMES HARDEN GOES TO
LeBRON JAMES AS THE FINAL
SELECTION OF THE ALL-STAR DRAFT.
SHAQ!
>> HE HASN'T PLAYED.
IS HE HEALTHY?
>> WHO IS THAT?
>> JAMES.
HE HASN'T PLAYED.
>> HE HAS MISSED --
>> WHAT HAPPENED?
>> HE GOT TRADED.
>> HE MISSED THE LAST THREE WITH
A HAMMIE.
NOW WE KNOW WHY LeBRON CARRIES A
CLIPBOARD WITH HIM TO THE DRAFT!
>> OH, MY GOSH!
>> EXCUSE ME.
HE IS RUBBING ICY HOT ON THAT
THING.
HE IS PLAYING THE NEXT GAME!
>> NO QUESTION!
HA!
>> K.D., NEXT YEAR, BRING A
CLIPBOARD.
IT COMES IN VERY HANDY.
>> YOU CAN HIDE YOUR FACE LIKE
LeBRON HAS BEEN DOIN